you know Philip Rivers probably those  guys you always let you know when he got  you you know I hated him for about two  years great guy love him to death  right but he was just hard to deal with  you could tell he studied your  weaknesses because you know he would  find those moments when you just weren't  paying attention and he knew he couldn't  attack me the whole game but he had his  moments when he would just throw it in  there squeeze it in there and God was  accurate ball looks like it's floating  but it's not I feel like he would say  something too hey would ya he got yeah I  got you right there or he you know you  come back and you jumped that one I'll  do that again or something a crazy like  that it's like half the time I don't  know what he's saying  yeah but I know he's just talking trash  and just you know he's the competitive  dude yeah and I appreciate it more now  than I did then